our discussion about the future of the
workforce would not be complete without
an exploration of what impact the
current innovations in technology will
have specifically artificial
intelligence over the past few years
there have been significant innovations
in big data database architecture and
artificial intelligence that are
enabling new business models and
products and simplest terms the
innovations and artificial intelligence
are equipping algorithms to make smarter
decisions about tasks and problems that
have so far been thought only to be
reserved for humans the accompanying
innovations and cheapening of hardware
that enables artificial intelligence
algorithms to read in process incredibly
large data sets has motivated more
entrepreneurs and technologists to
innovate with artificial intelligence
many think that the implications for the
workplace will hurt workers similar to
how the Industrial Revolution displaced
many workers through the creation of
tech that was cheaper and overall more
efficient than people people believe
that AI will replace and not just
blue-collar workers but also
white-collar workers however the fact is
that the impact on workers is under our
control the control of entrepreneurs
technologists and everyday citizens that
are part of the workforce business
owners and workers can harness AI to
augment human intelligence in the
workplace to creatively improve
decision-making instead of replacing it
here is Rob hi the CTO of IBM Watson one
of the primary rd leaders in the AI
space making this exact point at the
2016 MIT technology conference right if
we if we become experts and everything
we're experts in nothing and so the same
phenomenon occurs within these cognitive
systems as well they can actually begin
to get a little bit confused and in how
to how to disambiguate question so a
couple points to be made about that that
said because each of these are distinct
we can actually set the system up based
on whatever is appropriate for the
application we're trying to solve for
for the case of oncology treatment
advice it's the goal is actually about
trying to identify
best treatment based on outcomes based
on standard of care practices and
clinical expertise based on similarity
this patient to other patients and all
this contribute to help Watson come back
with an ordered list of potential
treatments but we again we're not trying
to make the decision for the human right
we're not trying to think for the human
we're trying to do is do the research
for the human so the human can then go
make the better sort of better in this
case the doctor so we're not going to
take we're not going to you know Watson
doesn't make the decision about what
treatment to give for the doctor it
presents the doctor a set of relevant
treatments that has been rationalized
based on all their information at a
speed that a doctor could not do on
their own including finding all the
literature that's relevant to support
why they should believe in that
treatment or not okay
so what specific types of disruptions
can we expect a I to cause for employers
and employees let's take a look at what
David otter a professor of economics at
MIT said in the future work panel at the
Nobel week dialogue of 2015 in terms of
employment as we said earlier people
have been worried for centuries about
displacement of labor and labor has been
vastly displaced right in the start of
the 20th century forty percent of us
employment was on in farms now it's
under two percent we had no idea what
was coming but it came we find uses for
ourselves and that's partly because the
technology augments us it doesn't just
replace us it makes the rest of what we
do more valuable right so you know I can
make more as an uber driver then as a
rickshaw driver not just because I'm in
in the rich world but because I have a
tool that makes me able to transport
people much faster and further and more
safely and more comfortably in a given
amount of time in many many ways tools
we make make our time more valuable
because there's always some piece that
we still have to supply and because that
that becomes the scarce factor that
raises our labor value so there's a
challenge so now let me say but let's
say I'm wrong and that we're going to be
all replaced by robots right that they
can do all the work we want is that a
problem well if it's a problem it's a
very unusual historical problem most
problems economic problems societal
problems are problems of scarcity of not
having enough of something enough food
enough power enough safety enough
shelter
in addition to changing the kinds of
roles that workers can take on in the
workplace hey I based innovation can
also impact social inequality for better
or worse to be determined by how we
choose to behave for example women and
people of color are very
underrepresented among technology
entrepreneurs that receive funding from
venture capitalists for their
enterprises adventure capital investment
goes towards a more diverse set of
entrepreneurs then we will see social
inequality improved positively here is
Amanda callow CEO of six sons a
predictive intelligence platform for
marketing and sales expanding on the
current under representation based on
her experiences the short answer is yes
I feel supported but I do feel so I go
to a lot of CEO events instead I mean
like on a panel like this last I was in
Hawaii just a little while ago 250 CEOs
as the only woman an enterprise tech on
less than one percent in this world and
it's it's crazy and it's it doesn't feel
right and I think it's because we're
missing that confidence and the passion
to go forward and want to dream big do I
feel supported by the men i think yes
I'm supported I think pretty much I feel
very supported especially my mail
co-founders are ridiculously supportive
and actually I think that they have more
faith and confidence in me than I do
myself which is amazing I think I have
had to maybe guide and teach some of my
VCS and other people in the world like
what's important and it's not always
just about like I think we're talking
earlier about the end goal of the
business and growing the business but
creating a sustainable company is also
about the culture and the people and I
think that what what we're missing in
today's workforce is putting an emphasis
on that in addition to all the great
technologies that we can do and that's
the thing that the women bring to the
table and you know I'm super proud of
our lack of attrition rate at six cents
like we don't have people leave and it's
because they feel supported supported
and heard and they can also be creative
and do amazing things in the work that
we're providing but I think there's I
mean I think we're all it's not
intentional when men aren't supporting
you know I was actually sitting on a
plane the other day talking to a
gentleman and he asked me what I did and
I never come out and say I'm a CEO this
company I say I work for a software
company I started talking about the
stuff that we're doing and then two
hours into the Congress
hey it's like what do you do there and
he's like are you in marketing and it's
like no I'm the CEO and he got up from
his seat and he had this like visceral
reaction like he and he didn't mean to
him then he sat down he's like I'm so
sorry I didn't mean to react like that
and it didn't intend to wait you're
missing it you know it was it was just a
lack of filter which we all have
sometimes you know when he was realizing
who I was in the company and I wear
braids and pigtails and I don't always
you know dress the part of you know
something else I always struggle with
being my authentic women's self I want
to maintain that while dominating in the
mail world that I'm in so I think there
are just there are levels of education
that we can give others for taking
income and social inequality between
genders will not improve unless we
choose to make fair decisions about who
gets opportunities to create and run
companies in the tech industry if we do
not actively monitor our biases we will
not be able to take advantage of this
period of innovation and wealth creation
towards a more equitable future there is
also an opportunity gap among people for
who gets to work within companies in the
tech industry Layla Jenna founder and
CEO of summer group an organization that
lift people out of poverty by enabling
them to do work in the digital economy
discusses this opportunity gap and how
we can mitigate it now interestingly
traditionally in the informal sector if
you're doing say construction work and
you go and you find your job by standing
on the side of the road and waiting for
someone to hire you as a labor
contractor there is no such thing as
getting rewarded for good work you might
put in a wonderful 10-hour shift but you
will get no five-star rating on a
website you go back to zero the next day
standing on the side of the road waiting
for your next job so I think that that
technology actually brings a lot more
transparency in areas like wages and
reviews and feedback that are very good
for low-income workers and I'll say one
last thing on this which is that Dave
and I were talking about this just
before the panel we so often assume that
technology has some kind of morality
built into it right technology in fact
is agnostic it's as agnostic as roads
waterways it's all about what we do with
technology we can choose to inject
morality into the technology we build we
can choose to build systems that
enfranchise the poor or we can choose
not to but we're not victims of
technological progress it's not
happening you know in a way that we
can't control at least until the
singularity happens at which point all
bets are off the first is job training
needs to completely change in the US
which is the best example I know it's
abysmal we are still training people for
jobs that are disappearing at an
alarming rate we are not training them
in how to be entrepreneurial and
marketing themselves the skill that you
need for 21st century jobs is marketing
yourself if Kim Kardashian can teach us
anything it's probably only that but
interestingly you know we're see all of
these new platforms require you to be
able to set up a profile to choose the
right kind of a photograph that will
attract customers to send a follow up
email to have customer service skills
and you're absolutely right that many
low income people and just to give you
an idea of how profound this is in the
u.s. we have one of our centers which is
less than a mile from the facebook
headquarters in Silicon Valley in East
Palo Alto which is a very poor community
and fully twenty five percent of our
incoming class for one of our trainings
last year had people who had zero
internet access at home and no
smartphone a mile from the Facebook
campus so we can talk all we want about
how technology is going to make
everyone's lives better but the reality
is that many people are disconnected and
if you didn't grow up having the
internet at home how can you possibly
understand how to market yourself you're
it's not easy to be an autodidact and to
learn how to teach yourself yourself
things on YouTube if you didn't grow up
with the internet
advancements in technology taking place
right now are incredibly exciting and we
all stand to gain from the most
consumers however as with other periods
of societal change we citizens and the
government have to ensure that the
opportunities to launch run and work in
these new enterprises is made available
to all members of society